hey this is presh talwalkar
start with the square whose side length
is equal to 50.
then consider a right triangle whose
legs have lengths equal to 40 and 30.
four copies of this triangle are placed
in the four different corners of the
square
each time the triangle is rotated 90
degrees as shown
the triangles do overlap each other
the question is what portion of the
square
is not covered by the four triangles
in other words what is the area of the
region shaded in green
i think jumer for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i will first review a principle of
similar triangles and then i will
present a solution of the problem
first similar triangles
as euclid said similar triangles are to
one another in the squared ratio of
their corresponding sides
if two triangles are similar in sides by
ratio of x
then the areas of these triangles will
have a ratio that's equal to x squared
now we've all seen this formula before
but why is it true
let's quickly go over a justification
if the two triangles are similar with
their sides in a proportion equal to x
then the heights of the triangles will
also be in a proportion that's equal to
x
the first triangle has an area that's
equal to its base times its height all
over two
the second triangle also has an area
that's equal to its base times its
height over two but this time the base
and the height are both scaled by x
therefore these multiply together to be
x squared
so the area of the second triangle is
exactly equal to the area of the first
triangle multiplied by x squared
this justifies the principle that if the
triangles have sides in a ratio equal to
x their areas will be in a proportion
that's equal to x squared
so now i will present a solution to the
problem
so here's our
diagram now let's do a little bit of
transparency on the triangles to see
what's going on behind them
notice there are four overlapping
triangles
so in order to figure out the areas of
these triangles let's focus on one of
the original right triangles
since its legs are equal to 30 and 40
its hypotenuse will be equal to 50
because it's a 3 4 5 right triangle
scaled up by 10.
now suppose this triangle has angles
that are equal to a and b
in the adjacent corner this triangle
will also have angles equal to a and b
but it'll be rotated by 90 degrees so a
will be here and b will be over there so
now let's focus on this overlapping
triangle
notice that it's also a right triangle
with angles equal to a and b
therefore this purple triangle is
similar to the blue triangle
furthermore we can figure out the length
of its hypotenuse
now this distance here will be equal to
50 minus 30 which is equal to 20.
then the longer leg of this right
triangle is equal to 40 so this distance
which is the hypotenuse of the purple
triangle is also equal to 20.
then the remaining length here will be
equal to 10.
now let's figure out the area of the
larger triangle
it has lags equal to 30 and 40 so its
area will be equal to 30 times 40 over
two
thus it's equal to 600.
now the similar triangle which is
smaller and purple this will have an
area that's 600 multiplied by the square
of the ratio of the lengths of the
hypotenuses so it'll be 600 multiplied
by 20 over 50 squared so this will be
equal to 600 multiplied by 2 5 squared
and that is equal to 96.
so we figured out the areas of these
triangles and now we can solve the
problem
we'll go back to the original diagram
and then we have four of these
overlapping triangles
so the area that's shaded in green will
be equal to the area of the entire
square
minus four times the area of the blue
triangle
plus four times the area of the purple
triangle
now the area of the square is equal to
50 squared which is equal to 2500
now we just need to simplify
we have 2500 minus 4 times 600 plus 4
times 96
we go ahead and do some arithmetic and
then we do some arithmetic again and we
get the area of the region shaded in
green is equal to
484 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you